a hundred billion dollars that's a lot
of money but maybe not enough money I
mean it's a sort of it's a funny
intermediate number so one thing I might
do is heavily invest in school and early
childhood education and try to get some
widespread more widespread development
in the United States and the other thing
I might do is go to some developing
African country and try to see if
there's a way to get them to actually
develop properly one hundred billion
dollars or even fit if you spend fifty
four hundred fifty domestic to fifty
billion in the foreign developing
country is problem you know place like
Uganda I don't know exactly what its GDP
is but that might be more than ten years
of its GDP so you could have a huge
impact in terms of building universities
building schools trying to build
infrastructure that would be very
important for their development and for
the robustness of their educational
system and their long term vision